cheating rules are different for men
and women let's go
let's play it
absolutely not that's cheating bro a
woman can't do that that's cheating it's
fine if i do i'm a man if a woman sleeps
with multiple people that's cheating
that's absolutely unacceptable on every
level and anyone it was going to sit
here and say you know it is acceptable
no it isn't men and women are not the
same we've never been the same this new
think idea that men and women are the
same is complete garbage that's been
invented right for our longest period of
human history men had a role in women
had a role men have never been faithful
ever look at history every single king
every single sultan had more than one
woman look at the history read the bible
it's all there never in any point in
history was there a woman with a bunch
of men and that was
probably nothing he said that you
disagree with so i agree i agree that we
do agree on one thing that men and women
are different i will say that sure so
that is a hundred percent true however
but different
well what do you mean by equal
women have rights men have rights we're
all equal here equality of opportunity
sure you've got a conservative your face
in here you can't just talk about
equality i'm with you
we are going on here we're different you
and i are different men and women i
don't know if all if you yeah you can
group all men and all women of course
there's going to be people that you know
stand out exceptions to the rule but
cheating is a decision
cheating is a decision you make so i
think what he's confusing is the desire
to act on something versus actually
acting on it for me
if you want respect from me i need to
expect respect from you so there can't
be a separate set of rules for men and
women on this
absolutely not and what i find is that
men often my husband i have this
conversation all the time i want to
bring it up to you jeremy will often say
to me and we'll often talk and they'll
say he'll say
men really good quality men when they
settle down with a woman they want a
woman
who hasn't been around the block 750
times who didn't sleep around i'll use
myself an example and get personalized
i've never had a one-night stand ever in
my life
everyone that i've slept with and there
have been more than one i didn't save
myself in marriage but
everyone i i was either in deep like
with or i loved i was it was it meant
something for me
that means something to my husband now
he's like i love that you lived your
life like that
the pro and i don't know if you would
agree with that that most men feel that
way but the problem for me is that men
have this expectation like oh we want a
girl ultimately we want a good quality
girl that we can take home to mom that
she made those choices but you need to
understand that we're just gonna [ __ ]
around for 10 years because we're men
and we need to do that and that's my
problem because what if i said well i
want a guy that made the same choices as
me
would i not be entitled to say that and
where are those guys
talk to me okay so there's our question
there or no i just want you to talk to
me but i want you to talk to me about
what you said number one anything you
want to pull from andrew i think he's
very entertaining i don't know anything
about andrew he's i think he's smart
he's a kickboxer badass
the the the metaphor that he's making is
there sultans and kings have had women
for eons right
which is true that's true and any time
that women want to kind of go they're
like yeah but that one queen cleopatra
that one time had a bunch of men like
they'll give one example but like
men can like genghis khan i think like
had
like
like a six of the puzzles yeah yeah like
a six of the population but should there
be a separate settlers for men and
should there be a separate set of rules
are you are we talking about kings and
sultans or men i'm talking about
regulations okay let me break down three
different things number one andrus
andrew tate views himself mentally
as a king or assault
whether you agree with him or not he's
like i'm the [ __ ] man yeah and i'm
not good looking i make money i'll kick
your ass i'll take your girl i do what
the [ __ ] i want if you don't like it get
the out that's him
i'm whether you agree with it or not i'm
letting you know
he can do whatever he wants he's some
people say that he's playing a role or
playing upper room some might say but if
you roll the tape that guy is a badass
world kickboxing champion like i hate to
tell you but that didn't read badass to
me it read sad empathetic just letting
you know the dude's a badass okay that's
not badass
you know what a badass would have said
no there's not a separate set of rules
for men and women a badass man would
have said when i'm with the women i
woman i respect her if i'm going to you
know demand respect from her i got to
give it back it's it's a matter of
character i may find all the women
attractive that doesn't mean i'm going
to act on it because i respect my woman
that's what a badass man would have said
he's not that ass who would you
i don't care if he considers himself
assaulted he's not a badass i'm with you
however
uh most men most and what i say is most
people are most people most people don't
get eight pluses and go to harvard most
people don't fail out of high school
that's fair most people are c students
you think most men feel this way what he
said if you gave a man an opportunity
and say you're going to marry the girl
of your dreams and you're going to live
with her and by the way she's going to
give you a pass once a year to sleep
with every girl you want how many guys
are going to say yes to that
i don't know every [ __ ] guy no i
disagree i'm letting you know no i'm
telling well there's alphas there's
betas there's gammas there's there's
different types of guys but most guys if
they can have their cake and eat it too
will most of them by the way so will
most women i would not do that i would
have zero interest in we've already
established that you're not the norm
most of my friends throughout my life
you may notice i have like a little bit
i don't want to say a male energy i
don't know how to say it i got you're an
alpha female i guess but so i've been
friends with a lot of the shoulder
i've had a lot of guys around me in my
life yeah i've had a lot of my best
friend is a male you have a good
relationship with your dad i have a
great relationship with my dad okay he's
probably raised you very well my dad's a
badass are you aware
that many a women
have very daddy issues daddy issues are
you aware of this of course well maybe
that's why you have such good upbringing
and why you're like have your head on
strong but that doesn't and there's
millions of women that are like i just
looking for a daddy replacement but
which is that
we need to forget about what the norm is
oh this is the norm and we need to talk
about what's right and what's wrong most
men can't do what andrew tate is doing
he abused himself as a king or a soldier
he isn't right he can do this is that is
what he's saying is that is that fair is
that right is that just well ask the
women that he's with because because i
don't need to ask the women
no respectable woman would put up with
that [ __ ] that well
a woman who respects herself a woman who
respects her body a woman who respects
her own mind is not gonna go mess with a
guy who's saying [ __ ] like that by the
way telling you straight up
if i ran around the streets of miami
saying what he's saying to the women
that i hang out with they'd be like get
the [ __ ] out of here but women aren't
going to put up an answer from you
what's up
is there a separate set of rules for men
and women on cheating um is there and
should there be
there okay that is about to get canceled
is there a separate rules on cheating no
i think if you're in a committed
relationship you respect the other
person and don't cheat now biologically
if a woman cheats and gets pregnant
that's a lot different from a man
a man can go impregnate
365 women this year
a woman can get pregnant one time so
biologically there is a difference i'm
not saying what's right or wrong in
terms of risk and yeah look at nick
cannon yeah homie just had another baby
because it's a tuesday that's fair but
that doesn't okay here's my question
do you believe there should be a
separate set of rules for men and women
i don't think there should be a separate
sentence there you go you don't agree
with him on that if you're a kingdom if
you're how about this oh if you're a
king if you're the 99.9 percent you're
gonna probably have to do exactly what
you're committed to
you're a king or sultan
in
uh
saudi arabia they've got
concubines galore yeah that's the
reality of today so what i'm going to
say
he can do whatever he wants right he
he can do whatever he wants and if there
are women who that works for them maybe
there's women out there that say oh i
don't care you know what i don't care if
you sleep with somebody else i think
there are women that does i'm sure there
are yeah oh yeah i'm sure there's plenty
of them out there by the way though the
hookster that was on freshly fit if he
you're going to live in my house right
you're going to be fed you're going to
be kept you're going to drive whatever
car you want you go shopping
i'm going to be [ __ ] whatever i want
she'll say sign me up right so what i'm
saying there's a lot of women two grown
adults you can do what you want it
doesn't affect me what i'm going to tell
you is that you don't get to call
yourself a high-quality man and you
don't get to say that you're with
heidegger you call yourself a
high-quality woman i'm not saying that
though i'm saying respect me and i'll
respect you i'm talking about respect
i'm talking about integrity i'm talking
about character i'm saying high quality
comes from those traits high quality
does not come from commentary like that
so that's all i'm saying you can you can
call yourself whatever you want like i
started this show saying you could call
yourself a cat you could call yourself a
dog you can call yourself a high quality
man but if you're talking about huh i
get to sleep around but my woman doesn't
you're not a high quality man you're a
joke if you like the short clip you can
catch another one here or you can catch
the full episode right here
you